PROFESSOR: So
atom-light interactions.
So we will focus just on
the electric field, E field.
Magnetic field effects are
suppressed by the velocity
of the electrons divided by c.
And that you know is the
fine-structure constant.
So magnetic field
effects are suppressed.
Ignore magnetic v
over c corrections.
With v over c,
again, of the order
of the fine-structure constant.
We will also think of
typically optical frequencies.
Lambda in the optical range.
So from about 4,000
to 8,000 angstroms.
And that's much,
much bigger than a 0,
which is about 0.5 angstrom.
So that's good for
our approximation.
That the wave is
relatively constant,
being the wavelength
so large it's
constant over the
extent of the atom.
So we will think of
the electric field
of the atom, E at the atom.
Our electric field, a bit of
notation, will depend on time
and it will be a real function
of time times a unit vector
to begin with.
This will get more
interesting because we're
going to be dealing
with thermal radiation.
So eventually, this
vector, n, will be pointing
and we will average
it over all directions
because thermal radiation
comes with all polarizations
and in all directions.
So there will be a little bit
of averaging necessary for that.
That will happen next time as
we wrap up this discussion.
So this picture is of
an atom sitting here.
And in particular, its
electron, which is the particle
that reacts the most
in the electric field.
And there is a unit vector, n.
And there's E of t here.
So the electric
field, E of t, is
2 E not in our conventions
cosine omega 3 times
the vector, n.
So what is the vector on
the scalar potential r, t.
It's minus r times E of t.
This is the formula
that gives you
E as minus the gradient of phi.
This formula is not true in
the presence of magnetic fields
in general.
There is a time derivative
of the vector potential.
But again, we're ignoring
magnetic effects.
So this is good enough for us.
If you take the gradient
of this formula,
the only r dependence is here.
There's no r dependence
in this electric field.
And in particular, we consider
the wavelengths to be very big.
And this is good enough.
So what is the
perturbing Hamiltonian
due to the coupling
of the electric field
to the charged particle?
And we'll say atom, and we'll
put an electron or something,
and we'll say the charge is q.
Eventually it will be
minus E for the electron.
But let's keep it at q.
Delta H is q times
phi of r and t.
So this is minus q times
r times E of t vector.
Or minus q times r
times n times E of t.
So so far, simple things.
We're just considering
the electric field and how
it adds on a charged particle.
This is, of course,
the simplest situation.
We will be considering in
this course soon, in fact,
starting next lecture,
the general interaction
of charged particles with
electromagnetic fields.
But for the time being
and in this approximation,
this is enough.
And we will define
now a dipole operator.
It's something that you
should keep in mind.
It's the usual thing
when you define
dipoles is you sum or integrate
over charges times position
vectors.
So this is a dipole operator.
And I emphasized the
operator because of the r.
When you have matrix elements,
transitions between states,
everything will have to
deal with those matrix
elements of r.
And that's why we'll
have a dipole term there.
So delta H at this
moment has become what?
Minus the dipole times
the electric field.
So let's do this.
Minus the dipole.
I'll do it here.
Minus the dipole dotted
with electric field.
Vector.
Or minus d dot n with
2 times the magnitude
of the electric field.
Or minus v dot n times 2
E not cosine of omega t.
Factors of 2 keep
us busy always.
And we have to get them right.
Remember when we did our
definition of perturbed
Hamiltonian we said that delta
H was going to be equal to 2H
prime cosine of omega t.
And our transition,
amplitudes, and everything
were written in
terms of H prime.
So this was our definition.
So at this moment, we
can isolate H prime here.
So H prime is everything
except for the 2
and the cosine of omega t.
So H prime, for our
problem of atoms
interacting with
electromagnetic fields,
is a dipole interaction.
And it's given by this
nice simple formula.
That's our kind of
important end result.
So if we have this
Hamiltonian, we
have calculated the probability
for transitions, for example,
from b to a, as a
function of time.
When we have a
harmonic perturbation
coupled to a two level
system, we have a probability.
We don't have yet a rate.
We just have a probability.
And this is equal to the
other one, to the reverse one.
It's 4Hab prime squared
over h squared sine squared
of omega ba minus omega over
2 t over omega ba minus omega
squared.
That was the formula we had.
In our case now, H
prime ab is that.
So we'll get the following.
4 E0 squared.
The E0 factor here goes out.
And then we will have
the matrix elements
of the dipole operator, d.n ab.
So it will all be matter
of the dipole operator.
H squared.
And these same factors.
Sine squared omega ba
minus omega over 2T
over omega ba minus
omega squared.
So this is the
transition probability.
We don't have a rate.
But the rate will come when we
integrate over all the photons
that contribute to this process.
And we'll get an exact
analog of Fermi golden rule.
So that will be next time.